we got it we got it this is the perfect
segue and now
donald trump did not pardon anybody
worth part okay hold on let me slow down
i think some people got pardoned who i'm
cool with there are people who like you
know
they were like regular people who
committed crimes 50 years ago or like 30
years ago
served 20 years and they had like no
opportunity for parole until trump
pardons or commutes their sentences
there was a lil wayne i'm actually
totally fine with that pardon
what was it he had like a drug charge
and a gunshot gun or gun charges
did he have a drug charge i don't know
yeah
yeah he was a phone with a gun i don't i
i think that's that's fine
but he pardoned steve bannon over the
build the wall thing but not
the veteran the the triple amputee
veteran who was also a part of that
he pardoned this the corrupt mayor of
detroit
he didn't pardon ross ulbricht or
snowden or reality winner or assange
or joe exotic he didn't even pardon joe
exotic yeah
come on joe exotic said he was too gay
and too innocent to get a pardon from
trump
but he actually did as that's what he
said there
this was a chance for him to to go out
with some sort of
i don't know pride isn't the right word
just integrity integrity doing the right
thing
yeah doing the right thing and and and
he did no look
look were there probably threats made to
him if he did this then the senate might
you know confirm the impeachment or
whatever i don't even know
maybe they said that if you don't do
then we won't come after you later
either way dude
you know it was an opportunity that was
missed and and it will leave a salty
salty it's
not an opportunity that was missed it's
a slap in the face to
anyone paying any attention steve bannon
steve bannon was literally accused of
stealing money from trump supporters he
gets a pardon
he accused no what happened with steve
bannon was that
people who donated to build the wall to
build the wall fund were told
that i believe the guy's name was
kolfage would not receive a salary
later on they indirectly were paying him
money through i think bannon
and that was fraud we still don't know
that we still don't know exactly what
happened i said he was accused
that's the that's what happened there
still was no court proceeding yet it's
going to happen we're going to find out
more
about what happened jack do you think
any trump supporter who donated money to
build the wall cares that cole phage was
getting a salary
no none no i i agree and so him so
bannon getting the pardon i say yeah
sure fine
but not the other dudes involved yeah
but trump supporters were happy to give
them money i think it's ridiculous they
went after him for this i still think
there's more to the case that we're
going to find out we don't know it
yet because the court proceeding hasn't
happened but look at the other people
kodak black
i mean he's a rapper that literally made
a music video
depicting trump supporters as the clan
and personally choking out
a trump supporter with a make america
great again hat so he he gets a pardon
israeli spies that were involved in real
espionage
get a pardon mercenaries accused of war
crimes
get a pardon i mean are you kidding me
and then we have assange snowden all
bricked
all of them just shunned ignored and
essentially what donald trump did is he
put the final nails in the coffin for
julian assange he is never going to get
out
he might as well just of executed him it
was donald trump who said in the
beginning
i love wikileaks then when he became
president he got pressed on it he said
well i don't know who julian assange is
and now
we're getting information that it was
him and his administration that led to
julian assange's arrest he's he
knowingly according to some sources was
getting pushed by many individuals to
pardon assange this was
widely popular amongst his base and now
he just totally ignored him and julian
assange will
rot in jail for the rest of his life
listen he he essentially signed
the execution order on him which is
absolutely disgusting and unforgivable
the q people are freaking out right now
because
you know trump left the white house it's
over and
uh if there was a conspiracy that i'd be
willing to believe at this point
is that trump was deep state trump's a
scumbag and he's a liar
if listen listen i don't really think
trump was part of the establishment
elites
but i certainly think they scared him
enough to where he didn't
he wouldn't he went up on a line okay i
would careful you know you know what you
know i think it was
i think once trump realized he lost when
he saw what was going on
and they went to him they they probably
told him they will come
after you if you if you free us on she
was probably like okay what can i do and
they said
rappers some friends just you know hook
your buddies up and then go away and
we'll leave you alone they won't leave
them alone they don't want them to run
over again
i think they're gonna they're gonna go
after them and try to crucify the guy
and he probably thought as long as he
played it safe they'd leave him alone
but
they won't he must be extremely stupid
if you think that's going to happen
because he got
played over that two thousand dollars by
mitch mcconnell like just
a little child smacked around and and
totally lied to about that situation so
what made him
think that mitch mcconnell was going to
tell him the truth after just screwing
him
about the major promise of two thousand
dollars it would be absolutely naive
and idiotic of him to do that but it's
not only the pardons that were pathetic
also his declassifications were utterly
useless
he succumbed to every classification
request by the fbi
his last order was resending an order
allowing politicians to become lobbyists
quicker are you kidding me let's go
legacy
he surrendered so that's what it is
trump got on his knee to the deep state
to biden
and said spare me and let me live i'm
sorry and they're not going to
of course they're not i don't know i
don't know about that
the precedent of prosecuting a former
president no i just i'm saying that they
they we don't do that right
oh they're going to love to these these
if they do that though but if that was
then that
opens the gates for that to happen i
don't care but look at the state level
zealous far-left prosecutors have
already been ramping this up yes
not safe you have nancy pelosi and
hillary clinton literally talking about
crazy conspiracy theories about vladimir
putin being on the phone with donald
trump during the capital siege
there's going to be a major overhaul of
people going after donald trump and his
supporters which he never stood up for
you know if and if if he did what you
said he did
to save his own but it's extremely
selfish and it's not going to work and
it's extremely idiotic in my opinion
sorry go ahead no
i was interrupting you kind sir uh no
they're
they're gonna go after the people yes
and the people more than they're gonna
go after him
they're gonna go after anybody that has
any whiff
of any dissident of anything having to
do with being
maga or even just white or even just
being a dude
it's all coming they can't allow trump
to happen again
they've been saying it since he got
elected they're saying it now they've
been calling for truth and
reconciliation they've been calling for
deprogramming
and the media will lie about it donald
trump bent the knee
and and begged to be spared and then
walked out doing very little in fact
making things worse it was
yeah he did more than just the lobby
yeah so he rescinded an executive order
that said that for five years after
someone serves in
i don't know what it is a political
office they can't be a lobbyist who
signed that executive order do you guys
trump
he signed the executive order and then
he signed it yeah that's what makes it
terrible
before he leaves so that he and his
friends can become lobbyists
in the next five years he surrendered to
the crony establishment
on the last day he said i won't do
anything the people have requested
tucker carlson went on tv and said
pardon julian assange
veritas put out the in put out the video
showing that julian assange
informed the deep state i'm sorry the
state department
freudian slip it wasn't it's true he
that
veritas part of this video where julian
assange called the state department
saying
someone is going to leak these documents
we don't have control over this
we want to let you know what's happening
proving that there was never an intent
from from wikileaks to publish
unredacted information to get people
hurt it wasn't them it was somebody else
you had conservatives and trump
supporters stepping up begging
begging trump do this one thing and what
did trump do
the corrupt former uh mayor of detroit
the rapper you mentioned to strangle a
trump supporter on video
he rescinded his own executive order to
allow the swamp to walk
right back in israeli spies accused of
actual espionage and actually dealing
with legal ramifications from it i mean
and then what is uh assange accused of
espionage right
he's not even an american citizen that's
the biggest
take here and if the united states is
able to get away with
shutting down a man throwing him in jail
driving him crazy
and essentially locking him up for the
rest of his life that is an extremely
dangerous president set that of course
is going to be used and abused
by the next president by the next person
in charge that of course now has this
huge power
to take anyone in the world for
publishing information that they don't
like
and saying that's it you're going to got
it the rest of your life we're throwing
the key away and not even looking back
you've got to watch v for vendetta it's
just such a good movie
i've been on the show what 10 12 times
now every single time we talk about it
and i still haven't seen i'm gonna watch
listen listen
next there's the scene where the
chancellor says i want them to know why
they need us
and then more importantly when v storms
the broadcast
center and displays the message saying
there's something terribly wrong with
this country if you
see what i see if you feel as i feel
meet me in front of the old bailey on
the 5th of november in one year
and they said he's a terrorist right you
see what they do
they want to make sure you're the
boogeyman here's the fascinating thing
to all these lefties who call themselves
the resistance
you were never the resistance you were
the the cronies you were the the
the lackeys of the establishment elites
who are trying to stop trump who was
kicking the door in
and the easiest way to understand that
is since when is the resistance
supported by every major multinational
corporation and the establishment
political party
now what's going to happen is you want
to know the real resistances
the people that are that are
libertarians like
like uh luke mentioned the people who
believe in individual freedoms
who believe in the declaration of
independence the constitution who will
now be called nativist
and white supremacists thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live
monday through friday at 8 pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time